[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Alert chimes ]
-I'm trying to sleep.
Who's texting me?
Santa Claus?!
-"Hi, Jimmy.
It's Santa Claus.
Ho, ho, ho."
Classic.
[ Laughter ]
"I just wanted
to let you know you're
on the naughty list this year.
No cap."
[ Laughter ]
The naughty list?!
This is awful!
My Christmas is ruined!
-Did someone say Christmas?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Mariah!
-Did someone say Christmas?!
Mariah, I-I-I just got a text
from Santa Claus.
-Oh, my gosh.
Okay, wait, let me guess.
You're on the naughty list.
-Yeah, how'd you know?
-Well,
I mean, hi, I'm Mariah Carey
and --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I get it, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
But I --
-[ Laughs ]
-Of course.
I-I-I just don't know.
I thought I was a good boy
this year.
-[ Sighs ]
What'd you do?
-Santa Sent me a whole list.
Here, take a look.
-Let me see.
Wow, Jimmy,
this is a lot of bad stuff.
-I know, I know.
What -- What -- What --
What does it say?
-It says you stole Questlove's
lunch from the office kitchen
and blamed it on Tariq.
[ Laughter ]
-I was hungry.
-You put a "Kick Me" sign
on Higgins' back...
-Yeah.
-...and then started
the Kick Higgins in the Butt
Challenge on TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
-I did that, but it went viral
and I didn't know how to stop.
What else -- What else is --
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Da da da da da.
It was your idea for Netflix
to start playing commercials?
[ Audience ohs ]
-Who doesn't like
the Geico gecko?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, come on.
-Okay. Uh...
You told Elon Musk
to buy Twitter.
[ Ohs and laughter ]
-I mean, he's already been
to the heavens with SpaceX.
I figured, now,
he could see hell.
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
-I don't --
I don't make these lists.
[ Laughing ]
I don't know. Um...
Okay.
Well, this part --
I mean, the drama on the set
of "Don't Worry Darling"...
[ Laughter ]
that was you?!
-Hey, all press is good press,
right?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Not in my opinion,
but anyway, okay.
Listen, the shoes
with the individual toes?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you know what?
That was a bad invention.
That's gross.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I'm sorry about that.
-Oh, gosh. Okay.
Well, what's this?
Wait a minute.
What's this thing with Adidas?
-Give me the phone,
give me the phone,
give me the phone, give me --
[ Laughter ]
just give me --
hand me the phone.
It was -- It was a bad idea.
Look, I had a --
[ Applause ]
-Jimmy, Jimmy, okay,
you've been really bad
this year.
Really.
-I know, I know. I guess
Christmas isn't coming for me.
[ Awws ]
-[ Sighs ]
Jimmy,
if Santa won't give you a gift,
I will.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Really?!
-Of course!
It's my new children's book.
It's a fairy tale called
"The Christmas Princess."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
-You're so welcome.
-"The Christmas Princess"?!
You have no idea --
this is what I wanted!
-I figured you did.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Mariah!
-[ Laughs ]
You're so welcome.
-Hey, what if we did something
really big and nice
for my audience?
Maybe that'll get me
off the naughty list.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We can try.
Wait, you mean like --
you mean like everyone here
gets a free copy of the book?
Like --
-Yes! That's a great idea!
-Yes!
Okay.
[ Boisterous cheering
and applause ]
[ Alert chimes ]
I love it!
Love!
-It's Santa!
-Whoo!
-I'm off the naughty list!
-Ye-e-e-S!
It's a Christmas miracle!
[ Cheering and applause ]
And you get a book
and you get a book
and you get a book!
-You get a book
-And you get a book!
-But wait, but wait, but wait!
-[ Laughs ] Oh, wait.
-Mariah -- Mariah...
-Yes, yes.
-...you got me something.
-Okay.
-What do you want
for Christmas?
-[ Gasps ]
[ Laughs ]
Oh, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Jimmy,
all I want for Christmas
is...
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
See you real soon.
[ Bells jingling,
upbeat tune plays ]
-Thank you for this book!
Mariah Carey!
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you!
♪♪